(hip hop music)
(screen buzzes)
(spooky music)
(gasping)
(breathing heavy)
- Why am I in the morgue?
- Because you're dead.
- No I'm not.
- Well, the certificate
here says that you're dead.
So, if you have one that
says that you're not,
I'd love to see it.
- I don't have any certificates.
I don't know what the hell
you're talking about, man.
I'm not dead.
- Well, maybe you're a zombie.
- Do I look like a zombie?
- Well, terrible skin, bloated,
yellow teeth, bags
under your eyes.
Shall I go on?
- Okay, I'm sorry
I'm not dressed for
the fucking prom,
but I'm talking to you.
Can zombies do that?
- They talk in Night
of the Living Dead.
- Oh, shut the fuck up.
I cannot believe I'm
having this conversation.
Look, my skin's not falling off.
Okay, I'm not a zombie.
- Well, Nicholas Holt's
skin doesn't fall off
in Warm Bodies, and he
talks in that one too.
- That's not canon!
If you think I'm a zombie,
aren't you afraid I'm
going to come over there
and bite your fucking neck?
- I can out run a zombie.
- What if I was one
of those fast running
World War Z zombies?
- Oh you're a fast?
You're a fast
World War Z zombie,
have you seen your own body?
Have you seen your
own fat human body?
Probably a slim chance
of that, right big boy?
(growling)
- Oh fuck!
There's a zombie behind you!
- What?
- Oh God!
- What's the matter with
your leg zombie?
- My legs are asleep!
He's gonna fuckin' bite you!
(growling)
- Well, okay,
so you want me to turn around
so that you can bite me neck?
- There's a zombie in there!
- I'm not falling...
(screaming)
- Oh my God!
Now you're a zombie!
- No I'm not.
(upbeat hip hop music)
I'm not!
(sobbing)
I'm normal!
♪ But don't it make
you wanna scream
♪ In heaven
♪ And shake your
fists up in the air
(screaming)
♪ Careful where
you stomp your feet
(growling)
♪ We know it makes
you wanna swear
(gunshot)